[Music]
in permanent punishment news phone ah-oh
submitted by sister crunch the funny
name of a good friend tattoo artists
inks the forehead of a teen after
catching him stealing that's so [ __ ]
dumb this in Russia no just sounds like
some gangster - you like that who steal
from a tattoo shop and what are they
stealing I know what are you stealing
I'm gonna steal your ideas bro in your
inspiration I'm gonna steal all your
[ __ ] stainless steel rubber gloves or
whatever you have their machines and
wires are like we're all breaking down
the contents inside your ass always do
all your nipple rings alright so this
takes place in Brazil oh oh Brazil pick
up black paintings and Thumba so there's
this video that went really viral but
I'm not gonna show you guys a video cuz
it doesn't really go anywhere I'm gonna
show you screenshots and the actual
tattoo that he created on this team what
happened was was that this team was
caught stealing a bicycle from a
one-legged man and I guess you could
ride with one like but it's gonna be a
lot harder and you're gonna go a lot
slower than everybody else
you stole a bicycle from a one-legged
man [ __ ] dumb that's really [ __ ] up
yeah and so the tattoo artist cornered
the team because he saw him do that and
he ended up tattooing his forehead so
this is what it looked like did he just
have a must machined I was like portable
and then he [ __ ] just sued instead
like that or did he just beat his ass
dragged him into his shop sat him down
on the chair prepared his table cuz you
have to prepare the table with like ink
and you have to put the gloves on you
have to wash his forehead and then you
yeah you get the needle you put it in
the machine you dip it and then you put
it on his forehead
that shit's a whole process maybe had a
shave a forehead a little bit
trying to run away he just did they're
just a little scared he's in his ass
beat that [ __ ] takes time just get my
[ __ ] ass beat me - yeah if I found
out I was gonna get tattooed on my
forehead
I might just kick my ass beat you're
lucky cuz you barely have any space I
know I'm sorry it's very valuable this
is like real estate in like Hong Kong
there's [ __ ] Tokyo right here it's a
billboard right there I should be paying
you for that ad this is still from the
videos what the kid looks like that gun
Isaac and this is when he was getting
tatted and he must not be very good
tattoo artists cuz there's a result whoa
he's saying I'm a thief
God he's saying I'm a thief and a loser
ha ha ha I feel bad for the kid that was
he tied down to the chair no he looks
like he was just sitting there he's just
sittin that in the whole video that's in
Portuguese I can understand they
probably beat his ass every time he
moved that's why but he looks so I mean
you could see he looks really scared he
did I die yeah he's like really
terrified and so this video surfaced and
they went by rule and apparently the
mother of this kid contacted the police
and the police arrested the tattoo
artist on charges of torture oh they
didn't make him a hero no that's kind of
crazy would he I think it's funny as
[ __ ] but it is cruel and unusual yeah
cuz he named him yeah he should have at
least like kept him and then called the
cops in the tournament I should have
been the extent of the exchange if it
was a rapist I would all be fine like
I'm a rapist on his forehead he's
speeding a bicycle and he's a kid as a
kid yeah yeah yeah you're right you know
how many things we we stole imagine if
we [ __ ] took like candy from CVS and
someone strapped us down and tattooed a
[ __ ] fat dick on our forehead and
said [ __ ] you would have never stole
again true I never have a job I would
have learned how to do it better next
time okay
learn oh my god now I'm just thinking is
that this dude is just gonna crowd his
hair so that just covers his whole
entire he's gonna go for that Justin
Bieber look or poor haircut I just think
that this kid is gonna grow [ __ ] up
now like it doesn't give it an
opportunity to grow like that doesn't do
that and when you're a kid you make a
lot of stupid [ __ ] mistakes and he
could have done a way different job
yeah that's upon that but we've said
we're an attack to somebody's face it's
not for stealing a bike his furnace
we're like raping or something it's
taking away something from someone that
can't be returned yeah a bike you can
return thank you you ate three children
maybe the tattoo artist had anger issues
maybe the way he stole from the
one-legged man was really [ __ ] up like
what if he like punched um pushed him
off the bike he fell on the floor
he's elderly and then he took the bike
and like it was just done so violently
that the tattoo artist was like walked
off walk even then I don't thank you
guys there's a tattoo across the
forehead I think what that kid deserved
was a [ __ ] ass whupping like to the
point where maybe he was like he almost
died I think this part is kind of sad
but the boy actually went missing they
can't find him of course because he has
that on his forehead so he's always all
scared he's like really worried for him
like they're thinking the worst I know
but the good thing is that he's easy he
won't miss you because they think he ran
away or it's out play no so what
happened was um
the tattoo artist said I don't know what
happened to this kid I tatted his
forehead and I let him go like he never
went home like they they never knew his
whereabouts at all cuz he's probably
scared uh face his parents because it's
gonna say I stole something right or you
think the tattoo artist killed him
that's what I'm thinking but I don't
know the tattoo artist killed um it
seems like the way everything happened
this is just me like my own speculation
there's not any report that I read but
just it seems like the way everything
happened like the tattoo artist had some
like ties with gangs or some [ __ ] cuz
like this team was like so scared and
the fact that he went missing and like
the the tattoo artist and his
was recording the video they both been
charged and arrested and they still
can't find the kid so it's like I don't
know but I'm just thinking the worst
that's just where my mind went I don't
think he killed them because if he was
really getting affiliated he would just
turn them you know make him one of his
minions and make him part of his gang
because now he has something on him and
then so now that kid has to work for him
that's true too and that's too much work
to tattoo and then kill somebody like it
doesn't it doesn't prove his point like
it's two of these right I just thought
the worst why would you want to kill him
you think like he liked to tell was that
what you're thinking like you would the
kid would tell on them or something I
have no idea it's just I'm telling you
it's just kind of it sucks no man like
he just he's a kid man it's when that
picture he looks hella young dude he
does he looks like 16 it looks like he's
in that awkward stage yeah you know
there's that awkward teen stage she
should be playing basketball you know I
stole a few bikes I wouldn't want
anything on my forehead after doing that
I never did it from a one-legged man
that's [ __ ] up you knew who you were
stealing from no I just got it off the
[ __ ] bike rack you could have stolen
from a one-legged man no but it's
different like one is you're pushing a
person off the bike and you're taking it
from them and another one is you're just
cutting the chain and riding off with it
no one said how this guy took the bike
how would he know it was one-legged man
cuz he probably knows the bike no but
tattoo artist saw it though it had to be
like in front of them or something I
don't know I think it's kind of funny
though I know you mr. Joseph you took
not by how I got no legs I think it's
because of the fact that he looks like
Isaac to itch is really like I'm just
like all important I hope Isaac doesn't
grow up looking like that
yeah duffle got a shape of a grey alien
head look at that he has a thin ass
[ __ ] cheek that goes straight down
like a he's like a guitar pick shape
head that's interesting that the tattoo
artist took that picture right it's okay
you know what the funny thing is and I
don't mean to make a joke about this
however if you just remove the tattoo it
looks like he's trying to be sexy it
looked like he had been crying of course
I'd be crying to surprise her it's like
a [ __ ] and there's probably a
certain sense of fear of death if
somebody sat there to get tattooed on
his [ __ ] forehead
that means there was no way out for him
yeah I would just run for my [ __ ]
life dude they really shined out the
spacing well either he like ran out of
space early so crazy dude damn he was
digging deep in there that I could tell
he [ __ ] it up
he wasn't delicate at all he'd uh he'd
dug deep
gastly with that [ __ ] for the rest of
his life yeah the punishment doesn't
really fit the crime
I don't think so cuz stealing isn't as
bad in my world yeah when the
submissions are people writing like this
adjusted news category as Gemelli and
justice I'm like know what you guys
don't know me that well I think stealing
is you know you can you could you could
you could be forgiven if you give them
back things or give equal value back
it's just possessions right but when you
take away things that can't be replaced
like somebody's [ __ ] been ripped
apart or something has been wrongly
wrongly done but you know what I take
that back because if I said if a burglar
comes into my house then I'm fair game I
can do whatever the [ __ ] I want oh you
know why when you enter the privacy of
someone's home that's just as bad as
rape that's why so here in public so
that's different yeah when you're in
public that's kind of like when you're
at the dog park
right yeah it's neutral territory right
if something happens out there that's
different but if you come into the
kingdom uninvited what's y'all but ho
[Laughter]
feeling a bike from one legged man I
would ask the one-legged man what he
would like to do because it's always
personal and justice is subjective to
the individual and if he was harmed or
he felt harmed it's up to him to decide
III believe in freedom of choice you
know there's a lot of true freedoms in
Jamali
in America not so much everyone has to
follow the same rule I don't like that
[ __ ] so if the one-legged man said you
know what as long as he says sorry I'm
cool and I'll be like cool say sorry and
then he said sorry and I go but you
still gotta get canned an [ __ ] once
but if the one-legged man goes I want
him to die then I'll be like all right
cool
that's your punishment for stealing a
bike yeah because you decided to violate
this person and you made them feel bad
tamale injustice hope you guys enjoyed
that video but if you didn't guess what
you can directly contribute to the
articles that we discussed just cruise
out over to the description box below
click on that link to submit your
article also for the next video click
rat up hey
[Music]